thank you guys uh we're here for uh the
trophy presentation uh the most
important part of the event
showing the trophy and presenting the
trophy to the winner
chakriar mamedyarov from azerbaijan
joined uh on the stage is michael
kordikovsky
the executive director of the grand
chess tour mrs agusta druggage the
president of the superbad
chess foundation and of course the
winner of the event
chakri armamediaro from azerbaijan mr
guzza druggage please tell us a few
words
thank you we are very happy to have here
the winner
we want to congratulate him and
i hope next year when romania will
organize again the granches tour
in the beginning of the may will be
again
and why not to win the trophy
next year also we are very happy that
the
superwet foundation organized this
and mostly because this year we have the
opportunity to have some romanians
also player and i hope that that's a
good
image about the romanian chess so
congratulations this is yours thank you
very much
thanks congratulations chakriar tell us
a few words
what does it mean for you to be the
first azerbaijan player to win
a leg of the grand chester uh
of course is very important for
azerbaijan
uh for others and chess funds and chess
lovers
it is um very good results for me to win
a super tournament like bucharest grand
tour
uh uh it's very good news
is we all now we will back
again maybe next year uh
very thank you very much for all
sponsors
uh all organizers granchester organizers
it was a very good tournament in
beautiful city and
everything it was very good we hope to
back again
thank you very much once again
congratulations chakriar
this conclu concludes our transmission
from here
in bucharest romania guys back to you in
the studio
thank you